If you want to hear about the secret murder
plot hidden within the world of Look-See,
stick around to the end of this video.
“If you yourself cannot release, then it
will come to take a piece…
But what does it mean release?
I’m not holding on to anything!
It couldn’t be talking releasing these 58
Things You Missed from CryptTV’s hit web-series
Look-See… could it?”
OK.
Alright fine.
I was going to keep them to myself but here
they are.
XX Things You Missed.
Before we get started, you’ll definitely
want to have seen the CryptTV web-series Look-See,
so if you haven’t seen it yet, click or
tap right here to watch it before coming back
to this video.
One of the things that’s never fully answered
in Look-See, is what the extent of the titular
creature’s supernatural powers actually
is.
In other words, how is Look-See able to use
its abilities punish its victims?
Starting in episode one, it looks at first
glance that Look-See has the ability to teleport
or at least move extremely fast to catch people
who aren’t able to release.
For example at the very beginning, this woman
runs into the bathroom as if she’s already
been chased, then checks all three stalls
to confirm that she’s alone.
She must do this because she already has an
idea of what Look-See is capable of and wants
to make sure she’s alone by checking every
inch of the bathroom she’s hiding out in.
She eventually decides to hide in the middle
stall.
Now focus on this crack in the door.
Did you catch that?
The creature crosses from left to right.
The only door in and out of the bathroom is
on the far right side.
So how did it get to the left side so quickly?
On top of that, The shoes end up appearing
under the stall back over on the left side.
This constant movement puts the viewer on
edge.
By breaking the rules of space, we’re never
sure where Look-See might appear.
There's another example of it’s uncanny
movement ability at the end when it appears
on the toilet seat behind her.
In episode 2 it warps out of the Daniel’s
bedroom, then later warps in and out of the
shower area to kill the woman Daniel is having
an affair with.
Then in episode 3 it shows up behind a bedroom
door.
So how is it able to do this?
Is it teleportation?
Episode 5 offers a couple possibilities to
solving this secret.
First, we see the creature double itself.
Daniel shows up at the hospital, but she soon
sees that he's also a victim of Look-See.
When he grabs her knee, pause it right there.
It’s Look-See’s hand with Daniel’s arm.
I would infer that whenever we see someone
who has died come back to life, Look-See is
behind it.
But Look-See also seems to possess the ability
to duplicate itself, because right here dead
Daniel and Look-See appear side by side.
You can pause it to where they’re on screen
at the same time.
There could be multiple copies of Look-See
helping create the illusion of teleportation.
But that doesn’t explain how Look-See appears
in rooms that the characters have already
proven to be empty.
Episode 5 may offer an answer for that as
well.
The protagonist has an opportunity to attack
to Look-See, but despite having no eyes, it's
extremely fast reflexes and movement speed
help it get away.
My theory is that Look-See has the ability
to move so fast, that if you let it out of
sight for a moment, it can rush to another
location.
And it can do all of this quickly and quietly.
That's not the only ability it has though.
It's super flexible, enough to bend down so
it's head is down by its feet.
It's strong enough to rip off body parts and
contort corpses.
And it can open and close doors without touching
them.
Honestly, it seems like it can do whatever
it wants, and tends to just toy with its victims.
I wouldn't be surprised if we haven't seen
the full extent of what it's capable of yet.
Despite all of this, it does seem fairly easy
to hurt Look-See.
It gets injured when it's hand gets slammed
in the door in Episode 2 and when she stabs
it in the head in Episode 5.
It doesn't stay down for long though, later
tossing the bloody fork back to mock her.
Now that we've covered what the monster can
do, let's take a look at why.
Each character receives the same note.
“If you yourself cannot release, then it
will come to take a piece.”
Let's break it down down episode by episode.
The first woman won't release herself from
a marriage that has clearly gone south.
If you've ever heard the term, “take her
hand in marriage”, you'll know why it's
symbolic that her hand was taken from her.
And similarly, if you've ever heard the term,
“She walked out on her husband,” that
could be the reason her legs are broken.
She is one of only two characters to survive
an encounter, so it's possible that Look-See
is actually giving her a second chance, so
that once her legs do heal, she'll appreciate
them enough to put them to good use, and walk
out on her man.
Another episode shows her writing tons of
notes for other victims, which makes me think
that there's kind of a Jigsaw-esque apprenticeship
going on here; like if you survive your game
you'll become a stronger person for it and
help setup the games for someone else.
In fact, the themes in this series aren't
too dissimilar to those in the Saw franchise.
In the next episode we see why she needs to
leave her marriage: because her husband is
seeing another woman.
The adulterous woman wants more than to simply
sleep with Daniel though, she's got her eyes
set on being the replacement.
She wants to be the girl whose face appears
next to him in that photo, which is why Look-See
takes away her head.
She needed to release her idea of being with
a married man.
There's evidence around the house that this
is the home of a man in a committed relationship.
The obvious one if the picture on the bathroom
mirror, but she also steps outside briefly,
where you can see two heart shaped chairs.
In the bathroom, a double shower head is installed,
one for the taller man and one for his wife.
There's more backstory on why Daniel cheats
on his wife later in the series.
But for now, let's move on to Episode 3.
The character in this one needs to release
his obsession with his deceased daughter who
drowned in an accident.
His release would be to move on with his life.
We find him in a sad state, preparing his
daughter's would-be 13th birthday cake and
eating it by himself while flipping through
an album of old photos.
This isn't just a one time thing for his daughter's
birthday.
He still has cupboards locked up, something
you would do to prevent a child from getting
in, and seemingly he hasn't touched the daughter's
room.
He wants nothing more than to embrace his
child again, so Look-See removes his arms,
while leaving his hands and twists his head
around to signify that he needed to turn around
and stop looking to the past.
Episode 4 is where things really get interesting.
It opens with the death of a high school student
at Harbor High.
Shortly thereafter, we discover that there
are already 12 victims being investigated
and this kid is the 13th.
Pausing the video to read the small text uncovers
the reason for all the deaths.
“Medication found poisoned.
Laced over the counter.”
This is the biggest event that has happened
so far in the series.
This headline confirms a mass murder plot,
and all signs point to it being someone other
than Look-See.
There's even a possibility that it goes much
bigger than what is shown on screen.
If medication was laced at a pharmacy, there
are probably other adult victims that we haven't
seen yet.
This community has a mass murderer on its
hands.
It's no wonder Look-See is drawn to this area,
because there must be countless people who
need to release.
This is actually where the whole saga begins.
The series presents the episodes in an order
that lets us discover more about the monster
with each passing episode.
But CryptTV later released a special supercut
with the episodes arranged in chronological
order.
It starts with this funeral episode, which
tells us a lot why there is so much grief
in this community; the reason that Look-See
comes here and pushes these people to release.
It is here that we see the beginnings of Daniel
and his wife's relationship falling apart.
I would assume they are at that funeral because
one of the 13 children who were poisoned was
theirs, and losing their child ours puts a
huge strain on their relationship.
It's here that Daniel meets the woman who
he later has the affair with.
Often in times of crisis it's comforting to
turn to someone you can relate to and unfortunately
in this case they develop a relationship.
Daniel's wife finds out and that leads into
the next episode chronologically, where Look-See
forces her to release in the bathroom.
Not long after, we have the infidelity episode,
and my theory is it's both Daniel and the
affair woman who are punished in this one.
When she gets out of the bathroom, Daniel
is nowhere to be found because Look-See has
already taken him, removing his eyes, because
it was his wandering eyes that initially led
him to check out this woman.
And by the way, it may not have been the first
time his eyes were up to no good.
Later that night, the wife wakes up in the
hospital and tries to kill Look-See, but she
is unsuccessful.
It's unclear how much time passes until the
final episode on the chronology, where Look-See
returns to punish the lingering father, at
the end of which Daniel's wife has become
Look-See’s note writing lackey.
So if she's been the one writing the notes,
then who wrote her note on the bathroom stall
door?
That's also answered in episode 4.
The short answer is: it’s this guy.
But let’s take it back to the start of episode
4.
The kid who dies in the opening shot, is featured
on the memorial, where we see this photo of
him.
I’m assuming that’s his sister.
Her name is Gretchen Holt.
Turns out she’s a cop, and she’s tasked
with cleaning up the evidence markers.
Her release is gonna involve moving on after
the tragedy, just like the guy from the 3rd
Episode.
But in her case, she wants to do a little
bit of investigation on her own and starts
to snoop around the school when something
out of the ordinary happens and she sees one
of kids who was covered in the sheets back
up and moving around.
As we know, this is a manipulation of Look-See.
After coming face to f--... well, after an
encounter with Look-See, we finally meet the
mystery man, and he actually saves her, but
ends up getting picked off himself by creature.
Gretchen actually survives, but the man is
forced to leave the message in the bathroom
before eventually killing himself at the start
of episode 5.
We don’t know a lot about this character,
so all I can do is theorize about what he
needed to release.
His death may not be the best place to look
for clues like I did with the others, because
it would appear that he committed suicide
to escape the torment of Look-See.
So he got out on his own terms.
All we know is that he was in the school at
night after the murders, sneaking around backstage.
You may not have noticed this in the background,
but when Holt surveys with her flashlight,
you can spot a girl facing the wall.
My first inclination is that Mystery Man is
doing something to her when he notices Holt
and kicks her out.
He also makes a brief appearance at the funeral,
looking down on the crowd from above before
making his exit.
At this point, he’s looking like the top
suspect to be the murderer.
My guess is he has some kind of grudge against
society, and his release would be to simply
let it go.
What he ends up doing instead, is killing
dozens of people, showing up the funeral to
watch the parents suffer, then returning to
the scene of the crime for some more foul
play.
He knows Look-See is going do something horrible
to him, so he ends his life on his own terms
to get away.
That’s the last death we see onscreen, because
the married woman ends up getting away at
the end of episode 5.
But that doesn’t mean the fifth episode
doesn’t still offer some clues about Look-See.
There are some elements that keep popping
up for each victim.
For example, the victims always seem to be
around flowers when Look-See attacks.
They can be seen beside the hospital bed,
the flower wallpaper in episode 3, also flowers
on the cups, on the jars, on the toilet in
episode 2 and again on the wallpaper in episode
1.
The wallpaper design resembles the cracks
on the walls in episode 4 and the newspaper
article in that episode encourages people
to bring flowers.
Back in the first episode, a butterfly design
is seen on Look-See’s shoes, so Look-See
could represent a butterfly going around from
flower to flower, or victim to victim, spreading
its message.
There are some other similarities, in the
attacks, but the meanings, if any, may not
be as clear.
For example, I saw an apple and banana on
the scene of two of the attacks, and two of
them take place around 6 o’clock.
That could have something to do with the stopwatch,
which comes in the shape of an eye, the one
feature that Look-See noticeably does not
have.
The stop watch could be a countdown for how
long someone has to “release” before they
are punished, but those details are yet to
be seen.
One conclusion I would like to make however,
is that the body parts that Look-See collects
from people make up Look-See.
Looking at its design, Look-See does seem
to be stitched together from a bunch of various
body parts, and we see the main character’s
own hand used to give her the stopwatch near
the end.
As I mentioned, Look-See is prominently lacking
eyes considering it’s name is a portmaneau
of the words look and see, the two verbs most
commonly associated with eyes.
It will be interesting to see what Look-See
ends up doing with Daniel’s eyes.
That brings me to my last Thing You Missed,
which is this title card asking about what
will happen next.
That may be the end of season 1, but it appears
that there are plans to bring Look-See back
for a second season.
You don’t want to miss out what happens
next, so I’ll leave you this link to subscribe
to CryptTV to stay up to date on Look-See
and plenty of other great short horror content.
Let me know some of your own theories about
Look-See and where you think the series will
go from here in the comments.
I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.